samedi sur rtl avec mimie mathy et mimie
mathy l'été vénère quand on parle de son
salaire elle se vénère 12 min bâti et
c'est même comparé année mr neymar mais
rien de comparable mrc comparé à nema
elle lui a mis attaque
elle est vénère regarder à l'époque vous
aviez dit 250000 euros par épisode
le salaire d'un comédien comme moi qui
commence à être âgé ça choque alors que
le salaire d'un footballeur qui a pas
joué comme neymar le transfert qu'il
coûte une blinde son salaire alors qu'il
est l'ami deux fois les pieds sur le
terrain il l'a toujours un bon mot
quelque part là ça ne choque personne
si vous pensez que la balle a pas
complètement tort c'est vrai qu'on parle
toujours des des salaires des comédiens
par exemple est sûre ça alors que le
chapelet des footballeurs et prennent
des millions d'euros et donc à damas
alors alerté les rives du saint louis
moi j'ai pas de problème à ce qu'il
vienne beaucoup d'argent peu importe
mais dire mais regardez-moi je commence
à être un peu c'est difficile j'ai
réduit mon cachet gelé / de regarder
comme je fais un effort ça qu'elle a
fait si j'aimerais quand même remettent
en perspective si on compare en smic moi
je gagne à peu près l'équivalent de
quatre à cinq smic par mois
je suis médecin je travaille
difficilement travaille dur comme moi un
très beau les allergies pas j'ai pas de
honte à le dire et elle a honte de son
salaire alors que si on met en
perspective et gagner l'équivalent en u
en un épisode quasiment vingt ans de
smic
je suis désolé de le dire et derrière de
dire oui il me regarde et il ya des gens
encore plus riche lui joue au ballon moi
champenoise et je trouve ça dommage
il suffit d' assumer oui je suis une
tête d'affiche regarder les scores
regardez ce que je rapporte oui je coûte
cher mais je rapporte beaucoup je
préfère ce discours a plutôt la
victimisation dix ans bernard garder les
autres armes auquel n'ont alors c'est ça
ne s'est pas du tout dans cette idée là
qu'elle a fait ça elle a réduit son
cachet tout simplement qu'effectivement
250000 pour que la série puisse vivre
avec tous les gens toute la technique et
tout le monde sait réparer la zone
non non bravo je termine elle a descendu
son cachet de moitié pour justement que
tout le monde puisse contrer cette série
et vivre et c'est pas un tacle année
mais alors c'est simple messieurs jean
michel critique regarder ce qu'elle a
dit sur son salaire
après jean michel jarre et gilles
regardez regardez alors je tiens à
préciser que pour que la série continue
j'ai baissé mon cachet pour qu'on puisse
continuer plus tôt car et et il faut
toute une équipe
mais toute une équipe au chômage mais
j'ai baissé mon cachet je vis encore
très bien mais j'ai largement baissé mon
cachet il a été divisé par deux alors là
bernard je viens crois que tu sois dans
un monde de bisounours mais à quoi le
dis j'ai baissé mon salaire pour que
toute l'équipe continue à travailler à
la bcc de elle continue à faire la série
après que deux tu as que ci excuse moi
mais on est on est de la nature humaine
est comme ça et je lui en veux pas du
tout mais je dis pas qu'à la pensée ou
jaser aux ag sont etc etc c'est pour ça
qu'elle sait qu'on est tous comme ça
isabelle rené basset saint michel pour
parer à ça passe et jean michel maire je
suis un homme tout simplement
alors pour le coup elle a peut-être un
caractère de cochon et moi je la connais
bien est parfaitement sincère quand elle
l'a parfaitement et pourquoi en douter
alors il y aura des géraniums elle
trouve ça très bien qu'elles soient
payés une fortune
pourquoi pas et je trouve ça très bien
que neymar sera payé une fortune ne
veulent pas d'argent c'est des
entreprises privées oui c'est des gros
contribuables
il pèse une tonne d'impôt pour l'état
français donc c'est très bien les 100
dollars d'armements badaoui je trouve
qu'aujourd'hui c'est effectivement je te
dirai quel est ce serait plus simple
qu'on assume nos salaires mais en france
c'est très compliqué de parler d'argent
oui et en plus de ça c'est une question
qu'on peut souvent aux femmes et pas aux
hommes est il souvent sur un ton de
reproche sommes là on me l'a reproché
plusieurs fois aussi mais il ya un
moment donné on rapporte aussi beaucoup
d'argent à quelqu'un au dessus et c'est
normal d'avoir une équipe est dans le
fait de rapporter de l'argent et c'est
en ça qu on est toujours très attaquées
effectivement sur les salaires mais
comme de par hasard c'est plus souvent
les femmes qui ont à faire à ses proches
benjamin par exemple il a décidé lui
beaucoup de problèmes il a parlé de son
salaire à chaque fois il s'en est pris
plein la gueule
donc là c'est fini a dit fils et moi
j'ai fait y à il ya dix ans mais peut
citer très gros points très fier ma vie
est gagnant par mois qu'elle fait
défoncer à défoncer paribas +1 pt après
les divorces sont passés par là
mais c'est moi je suis pour les
comédiens c'est vrai que quand on monte
une série sur une tête d'affiché
elle fait bosser c'est vrai 200
personnes va pas se mentir il ya une
production il ya déjà plein dedans c'est
parce qu'elle a fait pour sa bande en
tous les cas quand on donne de l'argent
à mimie mathy sur un film et c'est parce
que sur son nom cette audience il pas
d'être en f1 n'est pas une entreprise de
charité leader de temps c'est qu'elle
rapporte
oui oui j'ai surgi depuis 30 ans
peut-être
ah oui ouais mais c'est pas important
que tu la connais personnellement en
fait y'a pas de calculs précis à faire
c'est juste que c'est bron une industrie
où on gagne beaucoup d'argent et parce
qu'on aura porte comme vous dites
énormément aussi la tête et adéquat pour
moi c'est pas c'est pas autre chose
c'est un jeu comme la musique où comme
faisaient la lessive liquide des modèles
lcd modèle économique
neymar ils gagnent plus d'argent mais
ils rapportent unifie rapporté nous plus
d'argent que minime at il fait vendre et
vendre des dizaines d'hommes vous par 22
maillots floqués à son nom
je me bats toujours l'argent des gens a
offert des maillots fini à vaugneray
formation est reversée à une association
je vais d'effroi non messieurs s'il vous
plaît je mets des maillots floqués à
bonon si j'ai mes poèmes d'enfants pas
mal ça je suis juste c'est le combiné de
fiches de paie chaque mois qu'on fait de
buzz et de deux personnes honnêtement si
vous comptez toumi au moins 100
personnes
bull mais beaucoup plus à peu près 500
personnes et 500 personnes au camp comme
on dit voilà new life et sa ville c'est
beau c'est 500 personnes s'il n'y a pas
de honte du tout fait bouger beaucoup de
gens voulaient l'augmentation vous sait
très bien